amber heard started only fans did you
see that
did you really no
he just wouldn't believe it he's
starting a conspiracy right now
what do you think about uh the verdict
well i think it was probably um good for
all people who believe in the truth
and the problem is there's like this
boys versus girls narrative that i think
we all get into on these things
you know and there's a lot of guys who
wanted a guy to win one of these things
yeah you know yeah yeah but it's just
not good to not be honest
and if you're doing that and you're
doing it to try to hurt someone yeah
like if you're purposely
changing reality you're lying about what
happened just to try to hurt somebody
right you're you're doing a [ __ ] up
thing because you're pretending you're a
victim
and it's so it's not as simple as you're
just lying
you're turning someone into a criminal
you're pretending you're a victim and
it's if if it's all not true
if it's all not true
it's a really bad thing yeah it's really
bad it's just bad for all of us yeah so
whether it's bad for w like someone said
that the the verdict is bad for women
i'm like that's crazy they're gonna say
that
that's crazy
it's it's just
not good to do [ __ ] like that do you
think it's pretty some guy beat you up i
don't know
i i could
i you know you watch the trial and you
form your own opinions unless you're
there unless there's direct evidence
and other than the evidence of like the
conversations they had that they were
both recording which is
[Laughter]
did they secretly record each other no i
think they i think they both knew so
they both knew
so they decided to have like a
performance conversation
because that's because if you're
recording it you're recording it knowing
someone else is going to listen so
that's not a real conversation like
you're putting on a show yes yeah it's a
it's a real it's like yes keeping up
with the kardashians knows the camera
there yeah they know the cameras are
there yeah that's true what are you
gonna get they're putting on a show you
need chris jenner on oh i don't need
them
yes
why do you need that i would what is so
fascinating there's a baby's never met a
demon before oh my goodness
why because i downgraded her from devil
but isn't she just crafty
yes
i think that's right
well she's like made the most with
whatever resources she had she went
forward
a
yeah
that's the crazy thing is i'm trying to
look at things with rose-colored glasses
and [ __ ]
there's so much defensiveness in this
world right now and there's so much like
what we we think of as um
like things that are completely out of
our hands like when you think of things
like
the war with the possible war with
ukraine that's completely out of our
hands we're all just sitting here in
this state of anxiety right like what
are we gonna do like if if russia
launches a nuke if some wild [ __ ]
happens if china invades taiwan
what are we going to do so we're in this
like perpetual state
of never feeling like i'm just living
life
because i'm living life under this
canopy of danger and doom yeah if it's
not that's climate change yeah if not if
it's not that it's the new variance
there's going to be new variants coming
in january get ready yeah it's like this
const but we're just we've got to be
aware of things but the problem with
danger is when it gets in the zeitgeist
like that yeah it it takes a long time
to clean that out yeah when i was a kid
the cold war days were happening and we
were legitimately worried that at any
day russia could nuke the united states
it came super close right
super close well it definitely did
during the cuban mystery crisis exactly
yeah that was that was a little bit
before my time
that was but not by much i'm old as far
as 54. but they they were worried all
the time man they had stop drop and roll
or what would it would you just stop
dropping cover or something like that
yeah
something like that but we when we were
in high school man it was a legit fear
like when that red dawn movie came out
yeah like there was a legit fear that we
were gonna go to a nuclear war with
russia and we would all get wiped out
and everybody had this kind of anxiety
about it it like stuck with you and then
when when the soviet union fell that all
went away and for a brief moment of time
it felt relaxed it really did yeah it
felt like we don't have to worry about
nuclear war we just have to worry about
[ __ ] up wars we just had to wear these
hot wars they're shooting tanks at each
other in the desert yeah
yeah as long as we have to worry about
nuclear war
you know so we like accepted a certain
level of war and now the nuclear war
part is back on the table and i think
that's one of the things that it flavors
all of our conversations whether we
realize it or not is we're all under
this like steady state of anxiety yes
and then climate change
and it's not saying don't do things
about climate change we should but yeah
all this how dare you all that why is
that advantageous to keep us in a steady
state of anxiety it's not that it's
advantageous it's human nature to like
seek that
it's human nature to try to find the
danger the problem is you're not
supposed to know about danger
with seven billion people yeah it's too
many [ __ ] people you're supposed to
know about danger in your community yeah
like you're supposed to have a small
tribe of 150 or so people and you know
about everything you can't eat and you
know about all the people that are
dangerous yeah yeah it's like 70 people
like dunbar number one i think it's one
but it's actually tiered i didn't know
it was tiered it's uh the dunbar's
number is you get a certain amount of
like intimate close friends that you
know well and then from there on it's
like you had 50 people who you know
their neighbor you don't know too much
about them and then there's like a 15
people
1500 people you can recognize 500
acquaintances 150 meaningful contacts 50
friends 15 good friends yeah interesting
all of that by far someone's got to get
kind of loved once you know a lot of
cool people we know a lot of cool people
yeah
someone's going to get cut
you got to get cut from my top 15.
it's like where's my space
in the store in your mind everybody's
like bro why am i not in your top nine
remember that your friends would want to
be the top nine like okay
all right man this is so silly
it's your myspace list just all over
that's your dunbar number bro
that's the thing that's like
i think we really are only designed to
interact with a certain amount of people
i think that's why interaction on social
media is so like hostile
it's so it's it's not normal you're not
supposed to be in interacting with that
many people it's like you got data
coming out like
it's like too much and i can't care
about you i just have too many people
it's too much that's 1500. yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] but do our brains adapt over
time you think i think they do i think
our brains are going to evolve
and they're going to eventually whether
it's through electronic intervention
which is the most likely scenario that
they put something in our brains and it
allows us to uh interface with each
other in a different way and elon the
way elon described it he said you're
going to be able to talk without words
that's neuraline yeah this is his
version of it but i'm sure there's
multiple versions do you think we see
that in our lifetime yes
yes i think we see that way quicker than
we think i think how cell phones took
over
when cell phones went from being like
who has a look at michael douglas on the
beach with that [ __ ] friend
greed is good [ __ ] remember those
[ __ ] in that movie
making phone calls no cord out here in
the sand doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah
drinking margaritas is shaping world
politics yeah you can't finish the movie
you cut it off right before then you're
like yeah yeah that's what it's good
it's like scarface i'm sad when he dies
i wanted 20 months ahead of the lift
yeah
i did guys that clip was brought to you
by blue chew best boners in the business
same active ingredients as cialis or
viagra but this is the true the only one
we rock with get yours for free at
bluechew.com
promo code andrew all you gotta do is
pay five dollars shipping